>> Katie: ILLEGAL FENTANYL'S
FLOODING STREETS ACROSS AMERICA
BUT DON'T COUNT ON DEMOCRATS TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY JUST REJECTED SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD PENALIZE
PEOPLE DISTRIBUTE IN THE DEADLY
DRUGS.
THIS CAN CARE LESS AS CVP SAYS
THEY SEIZED THOUSANDS OF POUNDS
OF FENTANYL AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER
, AND SEIZURES HAVE RAISED
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR.
90,000 AMERICAN PEOPLE LAST YEAR
OVERDOSED ON FENTANYL, THE
CRISIS GOT WORSE AS A RESULT,
THEY WENT TO THE STREETS AND IT
WAS LACED WITH OTHER DRUGS,
WHICH CAUSE OVERDOSES, AND
DEMOCRATS DON'T SEEM TO WANT TO
IMPLEMENT ANY HARSHER PENALTIES
FOR CARTELS INVOLVED IN BRINGING
IT INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> Geraldo: I REMEMBER THE
CRACK EXPERIENCE, WHERE CRACK AS
OPPOSED TO POWDERED COCAINE WAS
TREATED MUCH MORE SEVERELY AND
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THE
PRISON FILLED UP.
I THINK IT'S A BAD STRATEGY.
I AM IN FAVOR OF THE BOARD OF
WELL-BEING IN PLACE, BUT IT
WON'T STOP THE PROFESSIONAL
SMUGGLERS.
THEY WILL GET THAT STUFF IN.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
ULTIMATE STRATEGY, AND WHAT I
WOULD DO WHERE I END CHARGE IS
ABSOLUTELY LEGALIZE MARIJUANA
EVERYWHERE IN EVERY CORNER OF
THIS COUNTRY, EVERY KIND OF
MARIJUANA YOU WANT.
THE CHEWIES, THE SMOKIES, ANY
WAY YOU WANT TO GET STONED.
THEY WILL DO IT ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER PAID IF THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO LEGAL POT, I THINK THE DEMAND
OF DRUGS LIKE FENTANYL -- IT IS
SO POTENT, IT WIPED OUT
NEW ENGLAND, IT STRUCK SO BADLY.
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO GET HIGH WHEN WE ARE THE
OTHER.
>> Katie: THAT'S AN ARGUMENT
THAT HAS BEEN MADE, THAT IF YOU
LEGALIZE MARIJUANA IT WILL MAKE
DRUG USE LESS PREVALENT.
BUT ACTUALLY, -- AND THAT IT
WOULD ELIMINATE A LOT OF WHAT
THE CARTELS DO, BUT THEY'VE SEEN
THE CARTELS ARE KIND OF MOVING
THEIR DRUGS AND THEY ARE
BUILDING INDUSTRIAL SIZED METH
FACTORIES TO REPLACE THEIR
MARIJUANA OUTPUT AS A RESULT.
>> Jesse: IF I COULDN'T FIND
POT I DON'T THINK I WOULD GO
LOOKING FOR FENTANYL, GERALDO.
[LAUGHS]
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S THE JUMP,
BUT THAT'S ANOTHER CONVERSATION.
THERE ARE REASONS THE DEMOCRATS
ARE AGAINST THE SENTENCES FOR
FENTANYL.
NUMBER ONE, LAWYERS.
THEY DO NOT LIKE MANDATORY
SENTENCES FOR ANYTHING BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T PLEA BARGAIN FOR
THEIR CLIENTS.
THE TRIAL LAWYER LOBBY OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY DONATED LAST CYCLE TO JAIL,
MANY MILLIONS MORE TO THE HOUSE
AND SENATE DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS A PROFITABLE DRUG
BECAUSE IT IS SO SMALL, IT IS
ALMOST UNDETECTABLE, AND THE
PROFIT MARGINS ARE HUGE.
A LOT OF THESE LAYERS REPRESENT
TRAFFICKERS AND THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY TO BE MADE.
THE MOBS CONTROL IT, THE CARTELS
CONTROL IT, SO THAT'S WHY YOU
NEVER GOING TO SEE DEMOCRATS
VOTE FOR TOUGH SENTENCING LAWS.
LOCATED?
JERRY NADLER, NEW YORK CITY.
ERIC SWALWELL, SAN FRANCISCO.
CORI BUSH, ST. LOUIS.
SHEILA JACKSON LEE, HOUSTON.
THIS HAPPENED TO BE THE MAJOR
DISTRIBUTION HUBS FOR FENTANYL
AND THEY ARE AGAINST THOSE TOUGH
SENTENCES.
HAVE I MENTIONED HOW MUCH I
DISLIKE LAWYERS?
[LAUGHTER]
I LIKE YOU, GERALDO, I'LL MAKE
AN EXCEPTION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY NOW DOESN'T
WANT TO REDUCE CRIME, THEY WANT
TO REDUCE PRISON POPULATION.
THEY BELIEVE THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED, A LOT
OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS THERE, IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST SYSTEM, AND THEY ARE
THE VICTIMS OF WHITE SUPREMACY,
SO EVEN IF THEY HAVE TO REDUCE
SENTENCES, IF THAT COMES WITH AN
UPTICK IN CRIME, THEY DON'T
CARE.
>> Katie: SO, GREG, YOU HAVE
THE OPPOSITE TAKE.
YOU BELIEVE IN LEGALIZATION, AND
FOMENTING MORE SENTENCING ONLY
EXACERBATES
THE PROBLEM?
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL, IN
TERMS OF CRACK, TWO AT GERALDO
WAS TALKING ABOUT, THE PEOPLE
WHO WANTED THOSE HARSH PENALTIES
FOR THE BLACK COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WAS REALLY
KILLING THEM.
BUT NOBODY ACTUALLY GOES TO BUY
FENTANYL.
IT ISN'T A DRUG THAT PEOPLE GO
LOOK FOR.
IT'S THE CHEAPEST INGREDIENT YOU
PUT ANOTHER DRUGS BECAUSE IT HAS
SUCH A HIGH POTENCY, SO THIS IS
WHAT KILLS ME, WHEN THE MEDIA
PRESENTS AN AUTOPSY THEY WILL
SAY OVERDOSED AND THEY WILL
MENTION THE DRUGS BUT THEY DON'T
MENTION WHAT EXACTLY -- THEY
WILL GO, "HE HAD XANAX IN HIS
SYSTEM."
IT'S BEEN DONE WITH A LOT OF
O.D.ES.
NOBODY ACCIDENTALLY OVERDOSES ON
XANAX.
BUT IT IS LACED WITH THIS STUFF.
THEY MAKE ALL THE DRUGS MORE
POWERFUL, AND IT'S REALLY
SLOPPY.
ONE WAY TO CRACK DOWN ON THE
STREET TRAFFIC OF FENTANYL IS TO
STOP CRACKING DOWN ON THE
PRESCRIPTION OPIOID USERS,
BECAUSE YOU ARE DRIVING THOSE
PEOPLES OF THE STREET AND
PUNISHING LAWFUL GAIN IN CANCER
PATIENTS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT STOPPED
BREATHING BECAUSE THEY TAKE THE
FENTANYL, IT MAKES IT EASIER,
YOU GET SO RELAXED HE JUST
STOPPED BREATHING.
THAT'S NOT AN OVERDOSE, IT'S A
REACTION TO FENTANYL.
THE FENTANYL TRADE SHOULD BE
VIEWED AS A TERRORIST ACT THAT
KILLED THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
COURTESY OF CHINA'S MASSIVE DRUG
TRADE.
CHINA KNOWS HE MAKES IT, JUST
LIKE THEY KNEW ABOUT THE WUHAN
LAB.
IF THEY DON'T KILL THE DEALER,
WHICH THEY COULD VERY EASILY
KILL THE DEALER, WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THAT.
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT HOW WE
ELIMINATE THE DELAYS.
WE MUST KNOW HOW TO DO THAT, AND
IT WOULD BE KIND OF NICE.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE, ANY WAR ON
DRUGS AIN'T GOING TO MAKE THIS
BETTER, AND NEVER HAS.
HAVE TO GO AFTER THE SOURCE AND
LEGALIZE IT AND GET PEOPLE, THE
POLICE AND THE GOVERNMENT OFF
PEOPLE'S BACKS.
>> Katie: DANA, IT'S NOT JUST
MEXICAN CARTELS BUT THEIR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CHINESE.
>> Dana: THAT'S THE ONLY POINT
I WANTED TO MAKE AND ALL OF
THAT, THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
COMING UP.
THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT ONE THING,
MONEY, POWER, AND REPUTATION.
OLYMPICS IS COMING UP NEXT TO
BERRY IN CHINA, THERE IS SOME
PUSH FROM PEOPLE SAYING THAT
BECAUSE OF THE HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES THAT SHOULD BE BOYCOTTED.
THAT'S A TOPIC FOR ANOTHER DAY.
HOWEVER, THERE IS A MEETING
COMING UP AT THE END OF OCTOBER.
THE G20.
THIS IS WHERE THE BIG ECONOMIES
GET TOGETHER, AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS DOING, AS
WELL, TO GET OUR ALLIES TO BE
SINGING FROM THE SAME SONG
SHEET.
IF YOU GO TO THAT MEETING WITH
CHINA -- AND I THINK IT'S IN
EUROPE SOMEWHERE -- WHEN THEY
ARE AT THE TABLE DEMANDING
SOMETHING TO BE DONE ON THIS
ISSUE OF CHINA LACED FENTANYL
PILLS COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES, THAT'S A WAR TYPE
ISSUE.
IF YOU WANT TO GET THEM TO
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HELP OTHER PEOPLE, TO FORCE THEM
TO CLOSE IT DOWN, WHICH THEY'VE
BEEN DOING, THEY ARE CLOSING
DOWN OF THE THINGS, THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT ANYBODY LOSING MONEY.
THEY CHANGE THEIR WHOLE
EDUCATION SYSTEM, THE